he is the host a million-dollar mile
that'll be making its debut tonight at
9:00 Eastern on CBS he's the host and
what you have you have people running
through the streets of Los Angeles
trying to run a mile and win a million
dollars but there are ten defenders six
men and four women charged with trying
to stop the contestants from taking home
that grand prize we welcome in Tim Tebow
who's also in the Mets organization and
I believe Triple A which we'll get to
coming up in a moment how would you do
as a contestant on million-dollar mile a
little bit they do this all the time and
they make it look really easy okay Tim
Tebow the football player in this let's
say seven years ago how would you do on
it I don't know I think it would be
pretty hard but I think we had some epic
finishes once I think so different about
this student some of the other shows is
it's you know
mano-a-mano down to the finish line and
that's pretty that's pretty cool do you
get a call from LeBron as the executive
producer to host this how does that work
I was a Bronco and they would come play
that nugget so I got to know each other
a little bit then and so in this project
you know came up with with LeBron and
his partner maverick and CBS and was
just some conversations we had and it
was something that I really was
passionate about and like yeah I love
competition and so you know I I kind of
understood the premise it was something
that really intrigued me but you're
gonna get to a point where you're gonna
have more of these opportunities but
you're still playing baseball like when
when do you make a decision on
do I want to do more TV stuff or I want
to continue to play baseball can you do
both make everything work so it made
sense for me
it only took a little under three weeks
be able to so where are you going to be
playing minor league baseball this year
sorry now in Syracuse the Mets triple-a
team nice and so it might be a little
colder in a couple weeks but I love
excited about it and you know one step
closer but it'll be it'll be a big great
challenge your evolution is a baseball
player let's say three years ago to now
what what's the biggest thing that
you've been proved upon oh my goodness I
think every area you know I think I'll
feel getting jumps obviously hitting
it's you know I think in every year yeah
I feel like you know from last year but
now if they jumps a lot of areas just
making it more natural being able to
play the game a little bit easier and
relax it it's just you know when you
take 12 years off the game there are
some things that just don't come as easy
and natural so I think it's being able
to get as many reps as you can and
certain things so that you could play
fast if you started at 20 playing
baseball finish that sentence I think it
would have been you know some of the
challenges wouldn't have been as hard
and I think you'd have had more time for
it but you know what I love this journey
that I've taken it's been so unique and
a lot of people you know you know
thought I was crazy when I did it but
you know I'm someone that pursue and I
love and this is something I love to
have enjoyed every step of the way and
so it doesn't matter
the end of the sentences whether that's
finishing as a big-leaguer and shuffling
whatever it is I get to do something
that I loved
he's Tim Tebow of course a million
dollar mile it will make its debut
tonight at 9:00 Eastern on CBS do you
know your walk-up song when you get
called up by the Mets when that first
time you go to the plate oh my goodness
well what kind of music do you like you
southern music country music well you
haven't thought of your walk-up song and
I'd have to give that some thought
though maybe I got one for Florida
Georgia line that would be the band yeah
in that year yeah so that's you so I got
to come up with this song from Florida
Georgia maybe they'll make one for you
they'll record one for you maybe The
Ballad of Tim Tebow I was also wondering
if you came out of college now with
today's NFL in today's die
is it more would you be more acclimated
for success in the NFL today with its
game and how you know it's everything is
read option and you have you know quick
quick throws or was the league more
suited for your style when you first
came in back in that plays the way that
I did I think in so many aspects of era
one of the big conversations was well he
was never understand about Florida but I
mean that's a question you never hear
anymore the NFL we're all on the shotgun
and I think we were able to help you
know change the game into the way it is
now and you know because they just put
so much pressure on teams they see more
and more teams going to the
spread more of a read option and I think
I would be much more you know able to
fit in a game nowadays this is the way
that I play but I'm so grateful that I
got to help you know some pressure on
the game to adapt and so many teams did
you know with cam coming early and
Kaepernick and and you know that was
just a time where you didn't see it Noah
thought there could be a read option
there but then you know when you have a
chance of being able to just show it and
you know put pressure on defenses the
game adapt but you also you know Kyler
Murray and Baker Mayfield you know that
the whole position it used to be you had
to be six four and be 225 pounds and
have a great arm you know now it's just
open to interpretation of what a coach
his offense can be which is unique and
it's great I think for the NFL like the
same you don't have to be you know six
four and there's a whole lot of
quarterbacks looking for it that never
what games and I think they're finding
people that that maybe look a little bit
different but they're winners and they
bring unique things to the table and I
think they're gonna give yourself just
more of a chance to win that way you
know so some of that you know I like
finding people that follow the way to
way more than high school college
because they're probably going to find a
way to win in the NFL so really it's
about witty game and did you reach out
to Connor Murray did he reach out to you
to get to know each other through I do
that it's a he's a great kid that's not
so much structure on campus yeah you
know I think the biggest thing that I
said I did it to share with Kyler was
you know between baseball and football
is
you know make the right decision for you
you know thing to affray through it but
those don't make what sense for your
agent or even your family members as
much as you know you want to make the
right decision for you and and whatever
is on your heart because that's what's
most important what happens first you
get married or you get called up by the
Mets well plan your wedding for November
just to be safe because I you're gonna
get called up at some point you're going
to I'm moving into a new studio I don't
have any Tim Tebow memorabilia here how
about the bat from your first homerun
that you hit this year yeah okay I mean
I'm thinking I don't want to put
pressure on you you got pawtucket coming
up next week and I think you can take
them deep so I scouted him out for you
Tim I think yeah I think those little
spotty so I'm thinking a sixth inning
shot so and then yeah and then we'll
we'll frame the bat and put it in the
new man cave yeah yeah we'll treat him
like they're the Georgia Bulldogs good
luck with the show tonight and hopefully
it'll be leading to a few a few more of
these situations able to host so good to
catch up with you thanks as always for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel two three
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]